for several days now temperatures have
been steadily climbing reaching at least
32 degrees at northhold northwest london
on monday the same heatwave is affecting
france portugal and spain where
temperatures hit 43 degrees near seville
on sunday in the uk the highest
temperature ever recorded was 38.7
degrees in cambridge on the 25th of july
2019. now we're still well short of that
but there is a chance the record will be
smashed later in the week of course it's
mid-summer so it's bound to be hot but
is it getting hotter more often these
are the peak temperatures of every year
back to 1900 color-coded from cool blue
to hotter red there are days over 35
degrees scattered through the 20th
century
but there is an emerging trend in the
last decade or so of reds and oranges
showing consistently higher peak
temperatures
that warming trend really stands out
when you look at average temperatures
for the whole summer not just the
one-off hot days the five warmest
summers on record have all been since
1976. so a clear trend but is it climate
change
yes says the met office it looked at the
summer of 2018 the joint warmest year on
record it found that the chance of such
a hot summer in a natural climate was
just 0.5 percent but because of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere that
had increased to 12 percent in other
words a record summer is almost 30 times
more likely now as a result of climate
change the warming trend will accelerate
by mid-century the met office predicts a
summer as hot as 2018 will happen every
other year and if greenhouse gas
emissions continue to climb as predicted
then by the end of the century uk
temperatures will peak at 40 degrees or
more once every three or four years such
sweltering heat is life-threatening
particularly for the young and old when
temperatures remain high for several
days heat wave deaths currently average
around 2 000 a year by 2050 they're
predicted to reach 7 000.
living in britain's heating climate is
going to be increasingly uncomfortable
for us all and deadly for some